another important distinction is that
any file you put in the cache has to
actually be downloadable if I put
something in here that doesn't actually
exist and then try to update the cache
again you'll notice that I get a
resource fetched failed event and the
problem is this means that the cash is
not being updated it doesn't just fail
to cash that one file it doesn't update
the cache at all this is to make sure
that sets of resources can be managed
together but be sure to watch the
console log and make sure that you're
getting the right things the important
point here is that the app cache
contents are used immediately even when
you're online the design of app cache is
offline first the user gets content
immediately rather than having to wait
for the network to respond